is this all just political tribalism gun
knuckle let me ask
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire Ben
Shapiro is back welcome back then hey
thanks for having me so is there a
political cost to victory I mean I think
there is the fact is that Roy Moore
there are credible allegations of child
molestation against him 14 year old
girls 16 year old girl and every senator
who is Republican who's gonna be running
for reelection this time is gonna be
asked why they wouldn't vote to expel
Roy Moore from the Senate if indeed he
has ceded now this does not mean that
it's it's all fun and games for the
Democrats I mean it's one of the reasons
that I think that the both Trump and
Mitch McConnell have reversed themselves
a little bit on Roy Morris because the
Democrats refused to offer Al Franken
despite obvious evidence that he was
attempting to grow up the breasts of a
sleeping woman so once there was
tribalism on the left it made excuses
for tribalism on the right but I don't
think that it's good for anybody and I
do think that Republicans do tend to pay
a higher price for perceived immorality
in politics than Democrats do yeah it's
really interesting because you know
leaders on both sides they're banging
their heads on this issue because they
want to have the political advantage and
you know when it's a stalemate I guess
you know they're they're both kind of
pacified in the moment but in the long
run it really is problematic because you
can't have someone in your party in the
Senate who has done the things that
Moore is accused of doing and at the
same time go after people like as you
have pointed out Anthony Weiner Al
Franken John Conyers and Lord knows who
else yeah that's right and I think the
Republicans unlike the Democrats have at
least pretended some sort of standard
with regard to personal behavior or at
least up until the last couple of years
I mean there's been this idea that
Republicans are the party of morality
that the party of Christian
conservatives and it's hard to maintain
that standard when at the same time
you're basically saying that so long as
somebody has an R by their name and
they're not pro-abortion so long as that
happens then they could be credibly
accused of child molestation I mean at
some point there will be a political
price to pay here and you do wonder you
know back in the early 1990s David Duke
won the Republican primary in Louisiana
to run for Senate and George HW Bush
said vote for the other guy I do wonder
if that sort of thing took place today
in either party what that party would
actually just own its own candidate is
the high road closed it might be I mean
they may very well be it may be that
we've reached the point in homes a
partisanship ler it doesn't matter what
the person on your side may have done so
long as that person is not of the other
side and votes the quote-unquote right
way if that's the case then we're losing
whatever common culture we had the idea
of a social compact where we're all
going to work together and at least
acknowledge certain basic levels of
character and decency that have to be
had in our politicians that's gone and
then it's just a war of all against all
and who cares what the personal
standards of the politicians are well
said ben shapiro thanks so much